[MUSIC PLAYING]
ACEMOGLU: Welcome
back, everybody.
It's a great honor to
be here for MIT's 150th
to introduce you to the panel
on Macroeconomics, Growth,
and Development.
I think we've had a great start.
It's kind of reminded
me how lucky I am
to have chosen this profession.
I think that
economics is not only
an exciting discipline with
a great history of ideas
and questions, but it's
also amazingly fortunate
to have all of these
questions more or less open.
So it kind of reminds me,
seeing all these debates
by the luminaries of
our field, that we still
have a lot of work to do ahead
of us, and lots of things
are still up for grabs,
not only in terms
of substantive questions,
but in terms of methodology,
and how to approach,
and how to think
about these big questions.
And I think the same
applies even more
to the topics of
this panel, which
is macroeconomics, economic
growth, and development.
And I can't think
of a better panel
to kind of give us
perspectives on this.
We're going to get started with
Robert Solow, who I don't think
needs any introduction.
And he's going to give an broad
overview of the development
of macroeconomics
and economic growth
over the last 60 or so years.
And then Peter Diamond
is going to follow up
with microfoundations
of macroeconomics,
in particular
emphasis on search.
Robert Hall is going to
talk about diagnosing
more short-term issues,
or the long slump,
which is somewhere
between short and long.
And Esther Duflo is going
to talk about the where
micro and macro meet, and
in particular in respect
to development
economics, which is
one of the central
applications of the economics
discipline, which has
made tremendous progress
over the last few decades.
So without further ado, I
will leave it to Bob Solow.
[APPLAUSE]
SOLOW: No, I'm going
to speak from here.
[LAUGHTER]
I think better sitting down.
Like any good economist,
I asked myself
what my comparative advantage
was here this morning.
And I decided it must be
related to my extreme age.
[LAUGHTER]
So I thought I would say a few
words about how macroeconomics
has changed and worked
out during a very
long period of time.
When I took my first
course in economics--
which, believe it or not, was
in 1940, that's 70 years ago--
there was no such thing
as macroeconomics,
and certainly no such
word as macroeconomics.
There were courses
in money and banking.
But all you learned that had
macro implications or scale
in money and banking courses was
you learned about the quantity
theory of money, and you
learned about banking crises.
There were also courses
in business cycle theory.
And they were certainly
macroeconomic in intention.
But the whole history and
volume of business cycle theory
had no general
framework within which
you could combine and
compare various ideas
about fluctuations.
There was, in short,
in 1940, no inkling
of a theory of aggregate
income determination
that you could use to
sort of standardize
stories about fluctuations
in aggregate incomes.
It's hard for people
now to visualize.
But this frame of mind, without
any macroeconomic notion
at all-- what we would recognize
as macroeconomic notion--
persisted for a very long time.
If you look at the Burns and
Mitchell Measuring Business
Cycles book, which was
published just after the war,
I suppose, 1946 or
so, you will see that.
And I will tell you a story
which illustrates it, and dates
only from 1961.
In 1961 and '62 were
the only period of time
in which I ever worked in
Washington, at the Council
of Economic Advisors.
And we-- mostly Jim
Tobin, Art Oaken, an I,
on this particular issue--
had some notions
which were put about,
about the evolution
of employment,
about the nature of the status
of the labor market then,
in 1961 or '62.
These notions were
strongly attacked
by Arthur Burns in
a bank newsletter
in a couple of articles
we found rather puzzling.
Henry Wallach also
found them puzzling.
Henry Wallach was a very good
economist, former professor
at Yale, and a member of
the Board of Governors
of the Federal Reserve System.
And Henry Wallach went to see
Arthur Burns, and said to him,
and what trajectory
of GNP do you
imagine to be
consistent with what
you have said about the
evolution of employment?
And Burns's reply was, oh,
I don't think in GNP terms.
So it was simply not
part of the vocabulary.
The fact is that macroeconomics
in that sense in which I'm
talking about it was really
born in Keynes's general theory,
in 1936, as AC Pagout later
acknowledged very generously.
And the Hansen Samuelson
multiplier accelerator model
and Lloyd Metzler's
inventory cycle model
are the earliest examples
of business cycle models
within the framework of
aggregate income determination,
at least aggregate income
determination on the demand
side.
The word, macroeconomics,
I didn't try to date.
It's almost certainly
due to Ragnar Frisch,
and at some later time.
Now, if you leave aside
the particular formulations
that people think of
as, quote, "Keynesian,"
end quote, which I'm
not interested in here,
the important characteristics
of Keynes's economics
for this kind of history,
of historical view
of the evolution
of macro theory,
were two things in my mind.
First, he wanted
to take seriously
the possible occurrence of
persistent aggregate excess
demand or aggregate
excess supply.
And secondly, he
wanted a macroeconomics
that would keep closely
in touch with data
and would keep closely
in touch with events,
not just the second-order
moments of time series,
but actual events.
It's no accident
that the evolution
of that kind of
economics went hand
in hand with the development of
the national income accounts.
I think either of
those is inconceivable
without the other.
Now of course the 1936
book, The General Theory,
is all about persistent
excess supply.
But when the war broke
out, a little booklet
on how to pay for the war
was all about excess demand.
By the way, someone once
accused Keynes of inconsistency.
And his reply was,
when the facts change,
I change my mind--
what do you do?
[LAUGHTER]
Now, from 1950 to the
middle to late 1970s,
macroeconomics was all
Keynesian in the sense
that I have just mentioned.
And most controversy
and discussion
was about accounting for facts,
not about points of theory.
And macro economists were
interested in such things
as the measurement
of potential output,
the numerical value
of multipliers,
of the elasticities
of key behavioral relations,
especially the components
of aggregate demand, like
consumer expenditure, business
investment expenditure, exports,
imports, the demand for money.
I want to be very
clear about this.
The great divide in
macroeconomics in those days
was between monetarists
and Keynesians.
But apart from debating
tactics and oneupmanship,
that whole argument
could be carried
on in terms of the shape and
variability of Hicks's IS
and LM curves, plus some
information about the supply
side and about
inflation dynamics.
Those were all
empirical questions,
but they're hard
so that there was lots of
room for a priori argument
and for ideology
to be dragged in.
And of course they
did get dragged in.
There was a sea change
in the late 1970s,
and that was primarily
event-driven.
What happened was a
period of inflation
without visible excess
aggregate demand.
The word, stagflation,
was coined for that.
That is to say,
there were episodes
which could not be
understood without talking
about supply shocks.
All the earlier attention--
except for growth theory,
of course--
had focused on
demand-side disturbances.
So neither the Keynesian nor the
monetarist inheritors had any
really ready-made analysis
to deal with that kind
of inflation, driven initially
by the oil shocks, of course--
well, oil, and grain as well.
So there was a temporary gap.
The gap was filled
in fairly soon,
but it provided an
opening for opponents
of this way of doing
macroeconomics.
Remember, I'm lumping Keynesians
and monetarists together.
And the opposition to this
way of doing macroeconomics
got its energy from two sources.
One, I think, you can
think of as ideology.
Think of it as part
of the general turn
to conservatism that
took place then.
And the other was to
tap into the latent
desire of all economists
for theoretical neatness.
And this is not
something I just think,
this is something I
feel, since I have it
as much as anyone else.
So after the 1970s, paying
close attention to events
got to be a bad thing.
After the 1970s, to
describe something as ad hoc
became a pejorative term,
roughly the equivalent
of child molestation.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is a very
serious matter.
And all of the discussion
turned to microfoundations,
which is what Peter is going
to talk about in a minute.
Bob Lucas made a very well-known
remark, a little bit later,
about how it would be
desirable to eliminate
the very distinction
between microeconomics
and macroeconomics.
There should just be economics.
I have to say I think that
was a profoundly foolish thing
to suggest, mainly
because it's impossible.
You can't answer the
questions macroeconomics
is asked to answer by
modeling the whole economy
as the interaction
of tens of millions
of households and millions of
firms and products, all of them
different, all of
them idiosyncratic.
Even the so-called agent-based
computer models that one sees
now are not trying
to explain events.
It would be like trying
to design an airplane
molecule by molecule.
For that reason,
what we mostly got,
apart from things
like search models
that Peter will talk
about, which arose out
of microeconomic, everyday
research, what we got
were primarily representative
agent-based models
where there's a set of
consistent preferences
that imposes some kind
of order and coherence
on observed the
macroeconomic outcomes.
So I'm a crank about this.
And I won't go on about it.
Just to say that all that
talk about microfoundations
in practice turned out
to be a word for less
plausible macrofoundations
for macroeconomics,
and was more or less
divorced from the need
to account for macro events.
This is related to the absence
of financial intermediation
of any realistic type.
By the way, nobody covered
themselves with glory
on that score.
But the logic of
representative agent models
almost precludes
serious autonomous
financial intermediation
with serious frictions.
Now, I want to take
one more minute,
since I think I was
expected to say something
about growth theory in the
course of this discussion,
and I got wound up in what
I've just been telling you.
So I'll take one or two more
minutes, and just say that,
so far as the future
is concerned--
and this fits in with some of
the micro discussion that we
had earlier in the morning--
what old growth
theory established
that the main force driving
trends in potential output
is total factor productivity.
So the natural
direction of research
would be to
endogenize part or all
of the evolution of total
factor productivity.
And a very good, very
productive literature
went down two paths, one
using the accumulation
of human capital as the main
way of doing that endogenizing,
and the other using
technological progress,
innovation, as the
way of doing that.
And obviously that has to
be an important interaction
between those two.
If you ask how much progress
has been made along those lines,
I think there's
some, but not much.
No one seems to
have developed a lot
in the way of stylized facts
or stylized near-facts,
near-theories along that line.
Maybe the truly
exogenous element
is too large, maybe not.
But the thing that
has always nagged me
about this part
of the literature
is how hard it is to--
and this is another
micro/macro line,
and the last remark
I want to make--
how hard it is to
tell a coherent story
that has total factor
productivity on one side
and a history of concrete
innovation on the other.
How do we go in either
direction from the story that
involves stocks of capital,
human and physical,
and stocks of labor,
or flows of labor
of various degrees of skill,
and some undefined total factor
productivity on one
side of the line,
and the other side of the line
is the transistor, the cell
phone, the Kindle that
will replace us all,
and things like that.
I think that's work
still to be done.
And it's going to be
a neat combination
of qualitative and quantitative.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
ACEMOGLU: Thank you.
Thank you, Bob.
Peter Diamond is
going to speak next.
And I think he will
use the podium,
and he will have a presentation.
DIAMOND: Jim Poterba
assigned me the topic
of the microfoundations
of macro.
And I, like everyone
else in the department,
always does what Jim suggests.
When I agreed to speak here,
my memory flashed back.
I was a graduate student
at MIT's 100th anniversary.
And I actually remember
sitting in Kresge listening
to Harold macmillan, although I
could not, for the life of me,
tell you anything
he actually said.
[LAUGHTER]
Even though we didn't
coordinate-- and this is,
I guess, part of Jim's genius--
my talk feeds directly
off Bob's in several ways.
Growth theory was a hot
topic in lots of places,
but obviously particularly
at MIT, in the '60s.
And growth theory was very odd,
probably unique at the time,
and still very unusual, in that
it was both a micro subject
and a macro subject.
And by subject, I mean
the people working on it,
some of my identified
themselves as macroeconomists,
some of them identified
themselves as microeconomists.
The modeling assumptions,
elements like that
were the same
across this divide.
The uses being made of
it were not identical.
But it was something that
crossed that micro/macro
barrier.
And what made that work was a
lack of a deep contradiction
between the standard general
equilibrium model that
microeconomists grow up
with and start thinking from
and the basic
growth model, which
was going to be used for the
kinds of macro purposes--
not the short-run
stabilization issues
that Bob was talking about,
but was actually addressing
things where the micro
assumptions seemed
to work for the macro ideas.
Since the '70s, we have seen
analysis based on the idea--
and this is the stuff
that Bob was criticizing.
I'm going to criticize
it a bit differently,
but we have the same warm
view of how good it is--
based on the idea
that the same dual use
would work for short-run macro
for business cycle analysis.
And of course Lucas and
Prescott are the key generators
of this literature.
The idea that a market-clearing
approach would work well
for short-run macro seemed to
me deeply implausible then,
and after watching it play
out over several decades,
every bit as implausible now.
If I could actually put Bob
Lucas in Bob Solow's camp
for a moment, in 2003,
Bob Lucas gave an address
at a HOPE conference--
that's an acronym, not a
subject of the conference--
and he was commenting
on-- it's titled
"My Keynesian Education--"
and he was commenting
on the kind of
financial crisis we
had recently, Latin
America, Asia.
And he said, the models we know
and work well with have nothing
to say about this subject.
I take that to be an acceptance
that event-triggered analyses
call for different
kinds of modeling.
In the early '70s,
there were some--
and I feel strongly Jim
Tobin was in that school,
and Bob and his remarks
tiptoed up to it--
who were opposed to seeking
a micro foundation for macro,
I think because they
thought it would end up
following the same
basically unproductive
market-clearing line.
And Bob also was particularly
vocal on representative agents.
I had a different view.
And I want to talk
about that today.
And not surprisingly, it's going
to connect to search theory.
The late '60s saw a rise of
a group of economists working
to construct a microfoundation
for macro out of search models.
Different researchers had
different starting places.
The desire for this
came from a sense
that standard macro modeling
involved micro concerns,
but did not incorporate them
in the same systematic way
with underlying modeling
that was standard in micro.
And the presumption was that
doing microfoundation modeling
would give rise to new
insights and a better basis
for even short-run
macro phenomena.
The famous Phelps
volume had its eye
on getting foundations for the
Phillips curve, which related
unemployment and inflation.
My own starting place in the
'60s was rather different,
having cut my teeth initially as
a general equilibrium theorist
as an undergraduate
studying with Gérard Debreu.
It was a desire to
do micro better,
to overcome the limitations
in relevance coming
from the excessive
degree of coordination,
that the standard general
equilibrium model assumed.
I thought that a proper
microfoundation for macro
would also lead to a better
micro, as well as a better
macro.
There are two key Keynesian
ideas that do not fit
comfortably in the basic
general equilibrium--
and I'll refer to it
as GE for shorthand--
model.
One is the large importance
of current income
in thinking about
things, exactly what's
behind the stimulus logic.
And secondly the
stickiness of wages,
the fact that wages
don't adjust quickly,
and that somehow
that's connected
with having a lot more
unemployed at some times
than at other times.
The challenge, as I saw it, was
to have a framework describing
the determination of an
equilibrium that had room
for both of these phenomena.
Alas, I can report
that we are still
working at trying to do this.
And while there's a bit of
insight into these pieces,
not much.
And where we have
made a lot of progress
is on focusing on
the labor market
as a partial equilibrium
piece of thinking
about the whole economy.
Bob Solow, in 1964, gave
the Wicksell lectures.
And the Wicksell lectures
were, as I realize right now,
a rebuttal to Arthur
Burns on why, at the time,
aggregate demand stimulation was
the right thing to be pursuing.
And the idea that
there was just a lot
of structural unemployment out
there, and aggregate demand
wouldn't do anything about
it, that that view was wrong.
And that lecture goes
through a lot of discussion
of details of the
labor market, and does
them-- no surprise--
very intelligently,
very insightfully,
but in a way that
was lacking an underlying
uniform theoretical
underpinning.
And that same kind of debate
between structural unemployment
and the need for aggregate
demand stimulation
is going on today.
And today, the discussion
takes a rather different form
because search theory has grown
up, over the last 40 years,
to have a whole bunch
of different models
to address different parts
of what goes on in the labor
market once you
assume what's going
on in the rest of the economy.
So it's partial equilibrium.
And the starting place
for this is a focus
not on the stock of unemployed
and the stock of the employed,
but labor market flows.
And here a 20-year average
calculates, from month
to month, what fraction of
unemployed workers in one month
are employed the
following month.
And the answer is 37%.
And what fraction of
unemployed workers
are actually out of the labor
force-- they're not employed
and they're not looking
for employment--
the following month.
And that's 33%.
And if you look at the people
out of the labor force,
and there's of course
a vast number of them.
Many of them have
no interest in jobs.
Many of them are not
actively looking for jobs,
but actually are
available for work.
And 4% of the "out
of the labor force"
people, labeled I, for
Inactive, in that figure,
are directly employed
a month later.
And 3 and 1/2%
are now officially
among the unemployed.
And what happens on
the employment side,
well, roughly 2%,
every month, flow
from employment to unemployment,
and roughly 3% flow
every month from employment
to outside the labor force.
Over that 20-year period,
roughly six million workers
moved into employment
each month,
and roughly the same
number moved out
of employment each month.
And the change in
unemployment was
based on the small difference
between the large gross flows
into and out of unemployment.
And the thrust of the modeling
and the empirical work that
has gone with it is to say,
let's focus on the flows
and assume the lessons
from the stocks
will be derived by
arithmetic from having
looked at the flows.
Now, the US is a
bit of an outlier
in the size of the flows.
But the flows are large in lots
of other countries as well.
Now, I've given you the
picture from the worker side.
There's also a great deal of
work in a wonderful new data
set called JOLTS, the
analytical work led
by Steve Davis and
John Haltwanger,
which looks at flows again
from the employer side.
So you interview employers,
and this is here quarterly,
not monthly, and you say,
do you have more employees
now than you did last quarter?
And relative to
employment, the increase
in employment where that happens
is 7 and 1/2% of employment.
And then you look
at other firms,
and they have fewer
employees than they had.
And so that's labeled
job destruction.
And you see it's
almost the same size.
The decrease in employment
in firms having decreases
and the increase in employment
in firms having increases
is very close to each other.
And the difference
between them is
what's happening with
total employment.
Again, the flows are huge.
The change in stocks is small.
If you're looking
at the full pattern,
hiring is about twice as
large as job creation.
A worker leaves, gets replaced,
that's additional hires.
And if you look at workers
having left an employer,
job destruction is part of that.
But quits is a big part of that.
So you see quits and layoffs
are about the same size,
on average.
Although in the course
of a business cycle,
quits and layoffs play
very, very differently.
So these large flows,
and modeling the flows,
and modeling how they feed
into wage determination
is critical for two
kinds of questions.
One question is we set
up unemployment insurance
programs.
They work at what I might
call ordinary times.
And they play a key
role in times like now,
with a big recession,
high unemployment,
where sometimes
automatically and sometimes
by explicit new legislation,
we get extended benefits,
we get changes in
benefit levels.
And so the question is, how do
you want to think about those?
First of all, you
recognize you have
policies that are in place
in good times and bad times.
Marginal tax rates
is another example.
Where in good times
we are focused
on the impact of inefficiency,
you go into a recession,
they're a big part of the
built-in stabilizer that hold
down the size of a recession.
So how do we want
to think about that?
And a key part that came out
of formally modeling search
is the idea that this process
is not inherently efficient.
Unlike standard modeling of
markets in micro, where demand,
supply, the market clears,
and things are efficient.
People searching
for each other--
workers looking for jobs,
employers looking for workers--
aren't in contact
with each other.
Their behavior
effects each other.
And so there are externalities,
there are inefficiencies.
And you can't start thinking
about the role of unemployment
without thinking about that.
And you can't start thinking
about the role of unemployment
without thinking about the
feedback onto aggregate demand,
the piece that isn't
in the literature.
So we're still a
long way from getting
to where some people wanted to
start, with the Phillips curve.
Search is being built into
otherwise conventional macro
models, looking at things
like sticky prices, and wages,
and how they affect the economy.
But it's a
microfoundation piece, not
a full-blown
microfoundation model.
And I look forward to and
hope for a big expansion
in the range of
microfoundation models that
will be consistent with
the general equilibrium
views of thinking about
the whole economy,
and the Keynesian view
of recognizing the fact
that we get, as Bob said, events
that really affect things.
And how the economy responds
to that is critical.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ACEMOGLU: Thank you
very much, Peter.
And the next speaker
is Robert Hall, who
will talk about the long slump.
HALL: Okay, well,
it's a great pleasure
to be here to recognize this
important event in MIT's
history.
MIT was very important
to me personally,
first as a graduate student
in the mid-1960s, where
my classmates have all
become just a hugely
important generation, including
Avinash Dixit and George
Akerlof.
Avinash and I shared an
office, and I learned
an enormous amount from him.
In addition, MIT is
important to my family
in that my older sister was an
undergraduate here graduating
in 1963.
How many women were
in the class of 1963?
I think it's, you
know, two hands' worth.
And she went on to and
continues an interesting career,
most famous in the
family for the fact
that she worked
for the guy who put
the @ sign in email addresses.
And my kids think that this
is absolutely legendary.
More recently, my daughter
received a PhD in economics
from the economics department,
six years ago, in 2005.
Now, the master of this
event, Jim Poterba,
assigned me to talk
about something which he
knew that I was thinking about.
It was not a random choice.
And that is to present
a diagnosis of what's
happened in the US economy.
I'll take the US economy as the
factual base for my discussion.
But similar things
happened in quite a number
of other advanced countries,
and are continuing to happen.
So you can think of this as
more of a worldwide analysis
than just focusing
on data from the US.
So let me give you
just a quick account
of the message of this
analysis and this diagnosis.
There were three factors
that built up in the US
economy in the past decade.
The first was a
tremendous splurge
of spending for housing
and consumer durables,
which left, coming into
the crisis and slump
period, an overhang of
durables-- houses and cars
in particular-- that
meant that we didn't need
to build so many afterwards.
And that overhang problem
is very much still with us.
The second was-- and closely
related to the first--
was an overhang of high consumer
commitments to pay off debt.
It's not just that debt existed,
but as we went into the crisis,
lenders forced consumers
to repay their debt,
and that had a huge effect
on the decline in consumption
that occurred in
the contraction,
and it's still weighing
heavily on and preventing
a brisk expansion.
And the final thing
is the weakness
of financial institutions
that occurred
as a result of the
financial crisis itself
in the fall of 2008
resulted in a big increase
in financial frictions.
Now all of this interacted
with another factor,
which is that we quickly moved
to an economy that didn't have
the normal ability of
an economy to absorb
a shock through
its interest rate.
We'd had a period of
low interest rates.
The Fed responded to the
crisis almost immediately,
pushing interest
rates down to zero--
the interest rate that it
controls, the Fed funds rate.
But that wasn't nearly enough to
bring the economy back to life.
And this problem of
relatively little
headroom in monetary policy--
because when you have low
interest rates to begin with,
the stimulus you can get is
strictly limited by the fact
that interest rates
can't be negative.
And that gave us the
slump in the slump
can be characterized most
efficiently in terms of data,
just as a big, rapid
increase in unemployment that
started in 2007, but greatly
increased in 2008 especially
toward the end of 2008.
And we have this
very long period--
the dashed line
on the right there
shows the normal
level of unemployment.
Current forecasts don't have
us getting back to normal
until 2015.
So we still have a long
way to go according
to expert forecasters.
I don't forecast.
One of the reasons is that
Paul Samuelson, who taught me
so many things, taught me,
if you have to forecast,
forecast often.
[LAUGHTER]
And there is a very deep
wisdom in that remark, which
says that forecasting,
if you get into it,
is always a full-time business.
And if you want to be an idea
person, a research person,
you shouldn't also
be a forecaster.
So this condemnation of my
beleaguered profession of being
a macroeconomist for having
failed to forecast the slump,
well of course we didn't.
We don't forecast.
We don't even do that.
So I think the real
test of our performance
as a profession is
not our forecasting,
but rather are we doing a
good job of understanding what
happened, and had
we done research
before that helps us understand?
And my reading as a biased--
I have to say that I'm
biased, of course--
as a biased reader of
that is that we actually
did a lot of research
that turned out
to be highly
material, especially
on the financial side.
There is a paper by D. Bernanke,
Gertler, and Gilchrist,
published in 1999,
that is a roadmap.
And that's not an obscure paper.
It's cited more
than 1,000 times.
A lot was known
that reads directly
on what happened on
the financial side,
and why financial
frictions rise when
you have a financial
crisis in particular.
So I want to defend
my profession
against some of the
things that have been
said, even by its friends here.
Okay, so the factors
leading up to the slump--
I want to talk mostly
about the slump itself,
but I found that everyone
wants to know my view of what
caused these problems.
First of all, there
was a dramatic easing
of lending standards during the
first decade of the century.
That resulted in a
lot of new mortgages
and bidding-up of
housing prices.
At the same time,
so-called deregulation--
and I condemn the notion that
it was ever even properly called
deregulation--
of financial
institutions occurred.
I think that the one most
important failure of regulation
is easy to identify.
In 2004 the SEC removed
its capital requirements
on investment banks.
So what are the names of
some investment banks?
Well, Lehman.
What about Lehman?
So the reason that Lehman
was able to do what it did,
which proved so
destructive, was that it
had no limits on the amount of
leverage that it could adopt.
And we learned that it
adopted a huge amount,
and then it fell apart.
As soon as asset prices
declined even a little,
Lehman necessarily
fell apart because it
was so highly levered.
So I think that the
regulatory side of this
is a very important one.
I mentioned before, there was
a buildup of consumer debt,
and of a form with the
expansion of debt, in effect,
people were borrowing
more to pay the interest
on the debt they already had.
It was unsustainable.
So the result was an
overshooting of housing prices.
And then-- it's a
very simple principle,
the housing prices, as
in most asset markets,
if it's gone up a
lot, it'll go down.
And that's what happened.
And when it
happened, it affected
these highly-levered
financial institutions
in a way we learned
so much about
in on September 15 of 2008.
So there was a sudden
realization that capital had
been depleted, there was
potential insolvency of a great
many institutions, and panic,
and some very aggressive--
and I think appropriate--
government action, making up
for the failure of government
action in earlier years.
And all kinds of
institutions besides banks--
investment banks, AIG's hedge
fund, money market funds--
all proved to be vulnerable
to this decline in real estate
prices.
There was a big increase in
financial friction as a result.
There was an
increase in spreads.
Let me pause for a second.
I'm going to de-synchronize
the slides here.
This slide shows
this big increase
in the relationship between
durables, household capital,
houses, and cars and
other consumer durables.
The red line on top,
you can see, rose a lot.
Nothing similar happened
on the business side.
The boom was very
focused on households
and very focused on real estate.
There wasn't much suspicious
or interesting going on
in the business sector.
That was pretty much normal.
What happened was a
big expansion of debt,
and a corresponding expansion
of building of houses,
and a tremendous
splurge of buying cars.
On the financial friction
side, one of the ways
we like to measure
that is a spread, which
is the difference between, for
example, what businesses charge
on loans and what
their funds cost.
And that, this is really
key to the diagnosis
that I'm talking about here.
The spread rose in 2008,
and it's still high.
We still have an economy with
excess financial friction
relative to normal.
And it hasn't gone
back to normal.
And that's one of
the important factors
that's impeding recovery.
If you look at that
on the consumer side,
you see exactly the same thing.
Credit card interest rates have
remained high at the same time
that the cost of funds to
banks to provide credit
to credit card borrowers
has declined substantially.
And that's resulted in
increase in the spread.
So there's another friction.
In addition, there's
been a huge restriction
in the availability of credit.
If you haven't used
it already, there's
a service at Google called
Google Insights that
is just tremendously valuable.
And I looked at a
variety of searches.
This shows that there
was an explosion
of people looking
for information
about withdrawal penalties.
Now, what does that tell you?
It tells you that they'd
exhausted their normal ways
of dealing with a financial
emergency at home,
and had to go to things
like taking money
out of a retirement fund, which
involves a very substantial tax
withdrawal penalty,
or taking money
out of saving instruments that
have withdrawal penalties.
And you can see, at the normal
level, it was cruising along,
and then suddenly it's shot up.
And again, it hasn't
come back down very much.
And that's again, a
very important issue
with respect to the
continuation of the slump.
Okay, so what happened, turning
to the interest rate side,
the Federal Reserve
responded very quickly.
By the end of October, the
Fed had done everything
that it can do with
conventional monetary policy.
It had pushed the fed funds
rate down to almost zero.
And it's still there today.
And forecasts shown
here on the right side
suggest that it's going
to remain at zero.
And certainly the
most recent decision
was emphatically
to keep it at zero.
We're far from the time when
we should begin to raise it.
This scenario suggests
that next year it
will begin rising,
but only by a little,
and won't get back to
normal again until 2015,
when the economy is thought
to be returning to normal.
So we're in an extended
period when the Fed's hands
are tied with respect
to its ability
to expand the economy further.
So that means that the
normal mechanisms that
should operate in the economy,
of lowering interest rates,
stimulating spending on, for
example, business capital
to replace the fact
that people don't want
to spend any more on houses.
We built, in some sense,
way too many houses
through the year 2006.
We can rest on our ores with
respect to house production.
We should be
producing other stuff.
But that would require a
decline in interest rates.
And that interest rate decline
cannot happen because interest
rates can't be negative.
And the result is the
normal equilibration process
of the economy fails in
a situation like this.
There's been a huge
outpouring of research
that I've contributed to
on this question of what
happens in an economy when
its interest rate can't
go below zero.
That's called a Zero Lower
Bound, or as we say, ZLB.
There's now a whole branch
of macro called ZLB studies.
And it's extremely
active right now.
Okay, so what else
happened that's important?
Fortunately it turned
out that nothing much
happened to inflation.
Inflation cruised
at right exactly
around 2%, which was the Fed's
desired level of inflation,
for an extended period.
At the beginning of the
crisis, it fell just a bit,
by about almost exactly
a percentage point.
And since then,
it's cruised at 1%.
Now, you might think all
inflation is a bad thing,
but that's not at all the
way macroeconomists think
about it--
quite the reverse.
I've said-- on
several occasions,
but this is the most
appropriate one--
Ben Bernanke would surrender
his MIT PhD in economics
if we could have
3% inflation today.
And why is that?
It's because what
we really care about
is the real interest rate,
which is the ordinary interest
rate, the nominal interest rate,
minus the rate of inflation.
What we'd really
like is for people
to perceive that
now is a great time
to buy stuff instead of later.
Well, there's nothing
like inflation
to get that mentality going.
Normally we don't
like to see that.
We want to keep
inflation under control,
because it's a sign of
an overheated economy.
Well, we'd like a little bit of
that overheated mentality now.
In the overheated economy,
people are buying.
now instead of later.
They're doing so guided
by financial incentives,
the interest rate.
We'd like a nice low
real interest rate, which
says buy now instead of later.
And that inflation
could deliver that.
Well, you can't revoke
Ben Bernanke PhD.
By the way, Franco
Modigliani once
suggested that my PhD should be
revoked when I said something
outrageous at a conference.
But it didn't happen.
I still have it, I believe.
[LAUGHTER]
And so we're lucky that
we have this continuation
of a moderate
amounts of inflation.
Okay, so all these factors
that I've identified
are going to continue as
far as anyone can see.
Gradually, things are
going to get better.
The overhang of
overbuilding in one sector
is going to gradually
come to an end.
We're gradually going
to fill up those houses
and build more houses.
The households are gradually
working down this excess debt
that they accumulated
in the last decade.
Financial frictions
are gradually
getting back to normal,
at least in some areas.
And all that's going to
give us a gradual glide path
of unemployment
back down to normal.
But another four
years, maybe more.
With respect to policy,
the policymakers that
were going to talk
this afternoon,
I understand they're all still
waiting for their planes in DC.
So maybe I can say a bit now.
First of all, I think the Fed
has basically done all it can.
It's made all the
right decisions
as far as I'm concerned.
But there's not
much more it can do.
And it is saying just
steady as you go,
and not engaging in any
more attempts at expansion.
Because it's basically
done everything it can.
There was a lot of interest
when the Obama administration
came in.
And MIT economists
were central there.
Larry Summers, who basically
got his PhD from MIT
because he took graduate
courses, including one for me--
a memorable experience,
I have to say,
and actually quite
a pleasant one--
and Christy Romer, who has
an MIT PhD in economics,
were very instrumental in
designing early policies.
One of them was to try to
take advantage of the fact
that when the government
buys more stuff,
every model agrees that
that stimulates the economy.
Any economist who suggests
that that doesn't stimulate
the economy hasn't
looked at a wide range
of models, all of which agree.
It's a numbered question,
but that number is positive.
And furthermore-- and
this is really important--
in a zero lower bound
situation, which
is what existed when the
Obama administration came in,
everyone also agrees that
the multiplier is higher
when the zero lower
bound is in effect.
So the numbers that
were put out for what
you could get from increasing
government purchases, I think
were about right.
And that was a big effort
of the administration.
But it failed completely, not
because the multiplier was low,
but because it's just
impossible to get the government
to buy more stuff.
The only government agency
in the federal government
that bought any more
stuff was the Pentagon.
But there was no
increase in other types
of federal government purchases.
So we just didn't do it.
And that's a repetition of
experiences we've had before.
The only thing that's under
discussion now that would be
interesting-- and it's an idea
that quite a number of people
have come up with--
is that if we could
use taxes to create
the equivalent of
inflation, that
would give us a huge stimulus.
And it could be done
in a way that didn't
have any budgetary impact.
But that's an idea
that's borderline crank.
So I don't think
it's going to happen.
But it's an idea that, if
economists ran the show,
it's probably something
we'd be doing.
And the last
comment I'll make is
that all this happened
because of regulatory lapses.
The most important thing, which
we've made almost no progress
on, the Dodd-Frank bill,
only scratched the surface
of what needs to be done.
We need to have robust
financial institutions
with lots of capital.
When I say lots of capital,
I mean like 50% capital.
There's no reason why we
shouldn't have a heavily
capitalized financial system.
And if that had been in place
and enforced, none of this
would have happened.
It's entirely the result of a
very substantial enforcement
policy lapse, of allowing
extremely highly-leveraged
financial institutions to have
important roles in the economy
without proper regulation.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ACEMOGLU: So I agree
with Bob that we
should be careful in making
forecasts, especially about
the future.
But it seems that I just
made a good forecast.
I asked Bob, so will you
be talking about policy?
And he said, no, no, no, that's
the panel in the afternoon.
I said, oh, I would have thought
you would talk about policy.
And he did talk about policy.
[LAUGHTER]
So we're very happy to
have Esther Duflo, who
is going to talk about, kind
of, an economic development.
It's going to be a
gear change, I guess.
DUFLO: I was trying to figure
out what could possibly
be my comparative advantage.
And I couldn't find one, except
that perhaps just before lunch
you might want to
see some pictures.
So here is a picture of Egypt.
In 2010, Egypt got $1.3
billion in military aid
and $250 million
in economic aid.
Egypt is the country that
gets the most aid from the US,
except for Israel.
Unemployment rate is about 25%.
And as you can see
from this picture,
there is deep, deep frustration
against a regime that
is both so corrupt
and extremely tired,
both physically and
institutionally.
If we had given all these aid
that went to Egypt to Africa,
we could have given
$20 per year per child
for every child under 5
who lives in Africa today.
So far some people,
like Jeffrey Sachs,
this is a sign that we
could have ended poverty
if we had had the
political will to do so.
With this $20 per
child per year,
you could have bought bed nets
to protect her from malaria,
deworming medicine
to make her stronger
and make her go to school
more, all of the immunization
that she would
need, and you would
have plenty of cash left over.
So if we don't do
that, it's because we
don't want it because
our priorities are wrong.
On the other side, we
have Bill Easterley,
who's actually a graduate
from MIT, who says that, no,
in fact this is a symptom, this
is a sign-- the Egypt case,
as many others, is a sign
that aid, in general, fails,
and that it's useless--
or maybe worse than
useless, because it
contributes to prop up regimes
which would have gone long ago.
So the issue is how do
we say who is right.
And it is very difficult
to say who is right.
If you look at
the aid to Africa,
it's been increasing steadily.
Those are the blue bars
here on the picture.
Now of course growth has
not really been stellar.
The GDP per capita
is the red line.
So some, like Bill Easterley,
would conclude, well,
it means that aid has
dramatically failed.
Of course we have
no idea what would
have happened without the aid.
Maybe it would have gone
downwards, like here,
or maybe it would have gone
upwards for that matter.
And this is like-- the problem
is what Jerry Hausman said,
we only have one world,
we only have one Africa,
and we just don't
have a counterfactual
to know what could possibly
have happened in this case.
So when people don't
use this kind of figure,
they use anecdotes.
So one that is a very popular
one on both sides of the aisle,
are Rwanda got tremendous amount
of aid after the genocide,
and it did very well.
And now the president,
Paul Kagame,
wants to wean the country off
aid, and that's tough to do so.
So one that is claimed as a
success both by Jeffrey Sachs
and by Dambisa Moyo--
by Jeffrey Sachs as
a success of aid,
and by Dambisa Moyo as a poster
child for self-reliance--
of course it's very
hard to arbitrate
between this he said, she said,
because we have no idea what
would have happened in
Rwanda if the policies
had been different.
So what has happened in
development economics
over the last few decades
is to try and move away
from those big, big questions--
can aid make a difference--
to much, much smaller
questions, much more
focused questions to which we
might possibly have an answer.
So it's a little bit, in a
sense, the empirical equivalent
of what [INAUDIBLE] said
is an MIT-style theory.
This is, in my view,
MIT-style empirical work, too,
not only MIT obviously.
So one of these questions,
for example, is malaria.
Malaria is a focus question.
I would agree it's
not a small question.
It's pretty serious.
It kills about 900,000
people every year,
give and take a few, 91% of them
in Africa, 85% of them under 5.
In fact, that's the leading
cause of under-5 mortality.
So how do we go about it?
Well, there's one
thing we do know
from various experiments
done by doctors,
is bed nets are an
effective way to prevent
the spread of malaria.
Long-lasting insecticide bed
nets are relatively cheap.
For about $10, you
can manufacture one,
ship it to Africa, and
teach a family to use it.
The problem is that
$10 is still too
much for many
African families when
the GDP per capita for a country
like Kenya is about $300,
for example.
So only about 10% to
20% of children at risk
sleep under a net.
And of course as conventional
public finance would tell us,
we should subsidize bed
nets, because malaria
is highly contagious.
So if I sleep under a net,
that helps the kid next to me.
And in fact, the
externalities are not linear.
Because the estimates are
that when 50% of people
sleep under a net,
the mosquitoes
don't have time to consummate
the parasite before they die,
and therefore there is
no transmission anymore.
So you can achieve
herd immunity from 50%.
That would give you a
very strong argument
for subsidizing net purchase.
In fact, we might
even want-- there's
no reason to stop at zero.
It's not like inflation,
which for some reason
is kept at zero--
interest rates, sorry, which
for some reason is kept at zero.
We could go and pay
people to use nets.
And maybe that's what
we should be doing.
So this is a policy that hasn't
been argued, for example,
by the WHO or by Jeff Sachs.
But then there's always a new
economics to come forward.
And there is this
very old principle
in economics called
sunk cost fallacy, which
is what you paid for
something shouldn't influence
what you do with it.
Because once you've paid
for it, you've paid for it.
And these arguments in coming
from psychology and economics
saying that maybe
the sunk cost fallacy
isn't a fallacy to the
extent that people actually
are influenced by it.
So there could be what people
call a psychological sunk cost
effect, which is unless
you pay for something, you
consider it worthless.
So the argument is that
if you give bed nets away,
people are not going to
use them as bed nets,
but as wedding veils or fishing
nets, like on this picture.
So the argument is very heated.
It's a very, very
ideological argument
with very strong position.
Of course there are
dollars involved, but not
very many dollars
when we compare
to the US economy or anything.
But a lot passion and ideology.
And sitting from
where I sit, this
is a bit strange
that this debate
is dominated by ideology.
Because it seems we could
pretty much resolve it.
It seems that what
we do need to do
to know whether bed nets
should be distributed for free,
or we should pay
people to use them,
or we should make
people pay a little bit,
or make people pay full
fare, is number one,
what's the price elasticity
of the demand for bed nets?
Do we lose a lot of people if
we start charging for them?
So that's the standard,
sort of economics 101
question, the empirical
equivalent of that.
Second is, if people
get bed nets for free,
will they use them or
will they waste them?
So that's the more sort of
behavioral sunk cost fallacy
hypothesis.
And third one,
which is something
that also come
forward, is that are
people are going to
be used to handouts.
So you give them the
bed net for free,
and maybe they use the bed
nets, but you can never ever
sell them a bed net again,
or clothing, or school meals.
They will always
expect handouts.
And all of these
questions, in principle,
you could answer by looking
at people at what people
do, with the caveat that
you have the Jewish mother
or Asian mother problem,
which is whoever decides
to pay for a bed net is probably
not comparable than someone who
will only get a bed net
if they get it for free.
So a big movement in development
economics in the last 10 to 15
years has been to try to
create a situation where people
are exposed to different
conditions or treatment
that are in fact comparable.
And the way you do
this is the equivalent
of the randomized
controlled trials
that are used in
medicine to test
the effectiveness of drugs.
So to give you an
example here, this
is an experiment
that was carried out
by Pascaline Dupas, who is
assistant professor at UCLA
and a former student of mine.
What she did is to
randomly select households
all over the place,
and offer them nets,
either for free, or
with partial subsidies,
or with full subsidies.
And she randomly
broadcast her vouchers
for the various
prizes for the nets
so that people are
strictly comparable.
And when we look
at that behavior,
we know that it's the effect
of the price they had to pay,
as opposed to any
differential selection.
And what do we find?
The first finding is that the
elasticity of demand for bed
net is extremely strong.
So for free, almost
everybody get it.
As soon as you make people
pay just a little bit,
the demand drops.
And when you get to $3, which
is only about less than half
of the full price, the
demand is basically all gone.
So the price [INAUDIBLE]
is very high.
So if you start
getting people to pay,
you will lose a lot of people.
Second question
is, are they going
to use it if you make
them available for free?
And there you find
sometimes no evidence
for this psychological
sunk cost effect.
People who paid for the bed net
and people who get it for free
are about as likely to use it.
I should say, it
means both there
is no psychological
sunk cost effect,
and the selection of people
who decide to purchase the net
is not affected by the
price they have to pay.
And the third question is
whether getting a free bed net
discourages future purchases.
And you find, in fact, if
anything, the opposite,
which is people who got
their first bed net for free
are somewhat more likely
to buy a second one when
it's offered to them
about a month later
at an average price.
So it seems people do not
get used two handouts,
they get used to nets.
Which is why, in
the end, there is
this learning and
information effect going on.
So what do we get from this?
Well number one, I think
we answer a policy question
of key interest.
When that paper of
Pascaline's came about,
that sparked a lot of debate,
and that did change policies.
For example, a big social
marketing organization PSA
changed their policy and
started to give bed nets away.
The government of
Kenya is also now--
this experiment was done in
Kenya-- government of Kenya
is distributing bed nets for
free in the maternal health
clinic.
Number two-- and
that's perhaps where
it becomes more interesting
from sitting in an economics
department-- is this
gives you a window on how
and why the poor make the
decisions they are making.
And here the big
puzzle is, given
that people are
willing to use the net,
seem to be valuing
them, why is it
that they are so price-elastic,
at least at the first purchase?
And that's not an isolated
thing for bed nets.
The same thing is
true for immunization.
Immunization is the
cheapest way to save lives.
It's very, very cheap
to immunize a kid.
The GAVI Alliance and
the Gates Foundation
are pouring millions
and millions
of dollars on the problem.
And yet, in a country--
there is about 20 million
children every year
who don't get the
vaccination they should get.
In a place like
Rajasthan, India,
where this picture was
taken, 5% of children
get the full set of
immunizations they should get.
This is a tremendous waste.
It's hard to imagine
a worse problem.
And what's going
on here, well, we
did an experiment
try to figure out
whether small demand-side
incentive would
make a difference in the
decision to get immunized.
And what we find--
this is a baseline,
you see almost no
one gets immunized--
after a year, there
is some increase
in immunization in the control
group where we did nothing.
When we introduced some camps
to make immunization easier,
some increase, to 17%.
But then when you start
giving this small demand-side
incentive-- we're talking
about a kilo of lentils--
the full immunization rate
jumps from 17% to 38%.
So it's a little
bit the same thing,
where you get these
very, very high price
elasticity for
preventive care, which
contrast with huge
demand for curative care.
And in fact, in
experiments I'm going
to spare you the detail
of, very low price
elasticity for curative care.
So people are willing to
pay just about any price
to cure their kid for malaria
once they have malaria,
but they won't get a bed net.
So that is kind of--
that's the mystery to
what could be going on.
Well, part of it could be
misinformation and mistrust.
That's not only
developing countries.
In this country
as well there are
ways where people decide
that getting immunized
is not so necessary anymore.
Part of it could
be procrastination,
a natural human tendency
to wait to do something.
With preventive care,
the cost you have to pay,
like going to the center
or paying for your bed net,
is today, but the
benefit is in the future.
So you might as well wait
a little bit to do it.
And that's why
offsetting the small cost
with a small benefit,
like for example
in the case of the immunization
program, is so effective.
Or maybe it's a combination
of the two things.
Regardless of what it is,
understanding exactly what's
going wrong is key to
design effective health care
policy in developing countries.
For example, what
are the lessons
that come out of each one?
One is absenteeism.
This is a closed health
center in Udaipur District,
63% of centers are closed
when they should be open.
Absenteeism is very [INAUDIBLE]
and it's amazingly costly,
because it introduces
both mistrust
and increases those little costs
that stand in the way of people
doing the right thing.
Secondly, information
is important,
but we have to recognize
that information
is going to be difficult.
Because learning
about preventive care
is very, very hard
for people who had no
high school biology,
and even for people who
had high school biology.
So there is a lot of trust.
And I think the right
message and way of diffusing
the information is hard.
Thirdly, we cannot possibly
overemphasize the importance
of making things easy.
And this is something that,
from the comfort of our lives,
we don't fully realize.
For example, we don't
realize that water
comes chlorinated in
our tap free of charge
when we moan about the fact that
the poor don't boil the water,
when we never had
to boil our water.
We don't realize that we have
to immunize our children,
because otherwise we
can't send them to school.
So that is a very
powerful incentive.
And then we-- we meaning
the policymakers, experts,
et cetera--
make big speeches about
the importance of the poor
really understanding
what they need to do,
and we shouldn't bribe
them to do the right thing.
We are constantly
bribed and helped
to do the right
thing in our lives.
So why did I spend so
much time on that question
of health care?
Just because it's, I think, a
good illustration of the modus
operandi in development
economics today.
Take a pretty focused
question, and bring it
all your attention
and your focus,
and try to answer it very well.
The question, of course,
is whether when we do that,
we sort of give up on the
large questions of how
our economy's going
to grow, and are we
going to get treat
of poverty one
day, whether we have
completely exploded
the problems into a
myriad of small problems,
and we are too far
from the big answer.
So obviously if I thought
the answer was yes, maybe
I would not have phrased
the question that way.
I do think this very patient,
step-by-step approach
is a very productive
way of trying
to understand how the poor
behave, why they behave
the way they do, and
therefore how we can possibly
help them get out of
poverty trap or get going.
And it's not going to be easy.
Because this is from
the accumulation
of these experiments
and experiences
that a set of general principles
can maybe start to appear.
But something that-- it
needs a lot of replication.
Something that works somewhere
may not work elsewhere.
It also means that
in a lot of cases,
you have to be like Keynes
and change your mind when
the facts change.
Because the facts
easily change on you.
But I don't think there
is another way, really.
And in a sense I think
there is an analogy
between this way of proceeding
and 20th and 21st-century
medicine, where you have a
back and forth between trying
to understand what a
particular molecule do,
and then going to a big project
like the Human Genome Project,
where the two kind of feed
off each other to develop
medicines.
And there are no miracle
cure to anything in medicine,
there are just thousands
and thousands of drugs,
and a better and
better understanding
of the human body.
And together, that amounts
for millions of lives saved.
So I also wouldn't
like you to be
fooled by the apparent
modesty of the objective.
Deworming sounds sort of--
very, very small thing.
It's take a pill twice a year.
How can that be
possibly important.
It turns out that deworming--
kids who have been
dewormed for one more
year than comparable kids,
when they were in school,
earn 20% more every year
when they are adult. 20%
more every year is a lot of
years of good growth in Kenya.
This study was done in Kenya.
And there has not been that
many good years of good growth
in Kenya anyway.
So these are actually things
that can quantitatively
be extremely important
here and now,
and have policy implications.
A few years ago, I was in Davos,
started this Deworm the World
organization, which is kind of
get all of these rich people
to give money to
deworming, which
is sort of pleasant
anyway, and gets this--
making some progress
in deworming
as many kids as possible.
So where are we?
Well, in a sense,
I think there is
a pretty clear moral
case for trying
to help here and now if we can.
I think there is an
efficiency case as well.
It seems like a
considerable waste
not to do the maximum we can
to help kids like these kids
get educated and healthy.
My personal view is
that it can't possibly
be bad for growth, in that
when and where the growth spark
starts, people who aren't
properly educated and healthy
will be probably more likely
to take advantage of it.
Even if it were wrong, I
don't really see a strong case
not to do the maximum we can.
And in a sense, I don't
think we have a choice.
I think that's a political
imperative as well.
An go back to Egypt--
I think the poor are not
going to sit silently
while we are trying
to figure out
how we can make the economic
[INAUDIBLE] or the labor market
work better.
And I'll finish with Roosevelt.
I replaced the world "country,"
which he was using in 1932.
"The world needs and,
unless I mistake its temper,
the world demands bold
persistent experimentation.
It is common sense to
take a method and try it.
If it fails, admit it
frankly and try another.
But above all, try something.
The millions who
are in want will not
stand by silently
forever while the things
to satisfy their needs
are within easy reach.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ACEMOGLU: Thank you
very much to all four
panelists for these
very interesting and
thought-provoking comments.
I would like to see whether
any one of the panelists
would like to make any
follow-on comments.
And if not, I think
we have a little bit
of time for questions.
And the microphones
are up front again.
Please come to either
of these two sides.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, everyone.
My name is [INAUDIBLE] from
Northeastern graduate student.
Last week, one of
my students asked me
a simple question in
Professor [INAUDIBLE]
test book about why the human
capital is never decreasing.
I found it very difficult
to answer such questions,
not because I don't know
the answers in test book,
but because of my
experience before two years.
I was hired by the
Chinese government
to do a survey in
Jiangsu Province
about economical growth.
So I spent half a
year to do survey.
But what I see is all
the local governments
they do is introduce capital,
introduce technique, and spend
a lot of money to
develop educations.
Because China always
lack of these things.
But the problem is that
all the foreign factories
invest in China, they just
use China as a factory, not
industry.
China become a part of
productions for those firms.
As a result, it has no such
demand for human capital
and techniques because
there's no design department,
there is no [INAUDIBLE].
So as a result, all the
people have a high education
level, the [INAUDIBLE]
to outside,
not stay at those
countries, stay
on those less developing areas.
So for those less
developing countries,
even they spend a lot of money,
time to develop a technique,
develop human
capital, as a result,
they never get
benefit from that.
So my question is that, based
on Professor Solow's series,
the difference [INAUDIBLE]
of economic growth,
they don't have stable
solutions in the equations.
So whether it is a time for
us to reconsider the power
and function of human
capital techniques
for developing countries.
Because these powerful
factories never
belong to those
developing countries.
Thank you.
SOLOW: I'm sorry.
I would like to reply
if it's directed at me.
HALL: Let me try to translate.
SOLOW: I don't hear very well,
and I could not make it out.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry about that.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ACEMOGLU: Bob Hall, I
think, will say something.
[LAUGHTER]
HALL: Well, a
one-sentence version
is, what's the role of human
capital in growth theory?
SOLOW: Oh.
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
I said earlier that,
for the long run,
it's extraordinarily
important-- supremely
important-- to understand
the evolution of total factor
productivity, with an eye, of
course, to asking the question
what a country or
some other policy unit
can do to accelerate the growth
of total factor productivity.
And the literature has produced
these two interrelated paths
by which total factor
productivity improves.
One is by improving
the skills of people,
and the other is by
technological innovation.
And they can't be
independent, because most
technological
innovations require
some set of specific skills
which need to be imparted.
And as production gets more
technologically sophisticated,
greater skills are needed.
It's very hard, from
the sorts of time series
that we have, to isolate the
relative contribution of these
or any other particular source
of total factor productivity
that you would like
to think about.
There is certainly no
doubt that human capital
is extremely important, not
only in the growth of advanced
countries, but also in the
development of poor countries.
And the big thing that China
has brought to the world economy
is a very large source
of low-wage labor,
first of all
employed in functions
that require very little in
the way of human capital.
And then the question is, can
the investment in education
facilitate, make possible, and
even make necessary the move
to more and more sophisticated
lines of production?
In the case of China,
that appears to be so.
I don't know whether
I've answered
the question in particular.
It's certainly the question
I would have asked myself.
ACEMOGLU: So we'll have
a couple more questions.
If you can make the
questions relatively brief,
because I think we
have limited time.
AUDIENCE: Good morning.
My name is Karen,
and my question
is for Professor Diamond.
And I know you were nominated by
President Obama to the Federal
Reserve Board once again.
So I want to hear your
opinion on the effect of QE2.
And I once heard you say you
are a believer of the market
and capitalism.
And I want to share
your opinion that
do you believe the US economy
can work its own way out when
the effect of QE2
wears off this time.
Thank you so much.
DIAMOND: The first
rule I was told
after I was nominated
for the first time,
and the second time,
and the third time--
which I think should
put me in the Guinness
Book of World Records--
is don't answer
questions like that,
it will just get in the way--
[LAUGHTER]
--of your being confirmed.
So let me skate around it.
First of all, Bob Hall said
the Fed has pushed the interest
rate down to zero, and there's
very little more it can do.
QE2 is something more.
And I don't think anyone thinks
of it as a huge deal by itself.
But I share the view that has
been expressed by the existing
governors--
I think I can say
that in public--
that it is helpful in
the right direction.
But I share the view
implicit in what Bob said,
that it isn't as
powerful as an ability
to lower interest rates
2%, 3%, or 4% more.
ACEMOGLU: Okay, one--
so I think we should--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: Bill Carlson, '68.
And I'm going to ask this
question of you, Daron,
and you can allocate
it to the panel.
You've published research
on dual labor markets,
the so-called "good jobs,
bad jobs" literature.
And I'm curious whether this
distinction between good jobs
and bad jobs is so
fundamental that it should
be in the microfoundations
of macro models
whose intent is to predict
the effect of stimulus
policies, especially when you
take into account Williamson's
work on the structure of firms.
ACEMOGLU: I think that's
a wonderful question.
But I'm not going
to answer it myself.
And I'll see whether--
Peter.
DIAMOND: Let me just
say that a major part
of the flows in the
slides that I showed
are flows of employed
people going to other jobs.
And so it's a quit, and
it's a re-employment,
and that that
generally represents
an increase in the
efficiency in the economy.
You could call it moving
from a bad job to a good job,
but it may be a
series of small steps.
That's a nice vocabulary for
something that's a continuum.
And there is a significant part
of the literature exploring
what drives it,
why it disappears.
Quits disappear we
go into a recession.
As Bob has noticed,
when the quits are gone,
then the replacements
disappear, and that that
affects hiring rates.
So this issue, in a different
vocabulary, is very much there.
It's not in the simplest
basic starter model
but I think it's the
kind of thing that
is recognized as
an important part
of the cost of a recession, that
these things aren't happening.
HALL: So David Autor, in the
MIT economics department,
has done some very
interesting research
that suggests that
we really need
to think about three groups
in the labor market, not two.
There's one group of people
who have very little training
and basically work
with their hands--
they do gardening, and
they take care of people--
and they're doing all right
by historical standards.
Then there's the people
who have graduated
from MIT, who are ready to go
out and develop new products,
and do intellectual
problem-solving work.
And they're doing
extremely well.
And then there's
a very sad group
in the middle who are
high school graduates,
but are the ones whose jobs have
been taken away, so to speak,
by computerization.
And they have suffered
the biggest disadvantage.
So rather than talking
about a dual labor market,
I think the next step is the
three-part, trinary labor
market, to get a good picture of
what the US labor market looks
like.
ACEMOGLU: Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE],, Sloan
School of Management, '74.
I took a course
from Professor Hall.
I don't really remember
what I learned.
[LAUGHTER]
HALL: That's good, because I
don't remember what I taught.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: But I remember
it was very important.
And I wish I had
learned more of it.
[LAUGHTER]
My question sparks
from your chart that
showed the spreads
on lending, which
are very high for both
consumers and corporates,
and they remain high.
And the observation I
want to insert into that,
and then ask a question, is
that the shadow banking system
is effectively on its back.
Structured financings
are not happening,
and they're not likely to
happen in any way in the size
that they're used to, for a
variety of reasons, mostly
good but many bad,
overregulation
being one of the bad ones.
Given the lack of
lending that is
taking place in
the high spreads,
how do you see the
evolution of the decrease?
The observation I had about
the structured finance market,
it basically has slowed
the velocity of money.
And I wonder to what
extent you see reduction
in spreads and incentives
that might be given to reduce
those spreads from lenders.
HALL: So on the business side,
the bulk of American business
is not dependent on borrowing
from financial institutions.
There's relatively
little leverage.
Where I live, corporations
don't borrow from banks at all.
Quite the country, they
accumulate almost mindlessly.
Like Apple-- Apple
has $50 billion
in short-term instruments
on its balance sheet,
not borrowing, but lending.
And the shareholders are getting
a little restless about that.
Of course there are
certain industries
that are credit-dependent.
And they are still definitely--
there's no question
that there's an impairment of
credit flows in certain areas.
I think, though,
and I think there's
been a big shift of the
thinking of macroeconomists
in this direction, that the real
credit-dependent sector is not
business, but it's households.
And the real questions
are the squeeze
that's gone on in the household,
where they were permitted
to borrow large amounts
in the last decade,
and then forced to repay
that over the last few years.
That, in terms of GDP--
the way I think--
is very much larger
than what I would say
is a relatively marginal issue
with respect to businesses.
Most GDP arises
in businesses that
have direct access
to credit markets,
if they need credit at all--
or finance.
They're mostly equity-financed.
The US business sector
is not highly levered.
Only certain sectors are.
Airlines are.
We used to say that
auto companies were.
But generally speaking, leverage
is not a factor in business.
It is a huge factor in
financial institutions.
But how important that is
for the business sector
I think is still up in the air.
It's the household side that
I think it deserves the most
attention today.
DIAMOND: Let me put
a different wrinkle
on the interpretation
of the household sector
and the word, business.
From the employment
point of view,
there's a great
deal of employment
that goes on with
small business.
And a lot of small business
is financed by banks,
and is financed by drawing on--
there's the household link--
their own wealth, the wealth
of families and friends.
And what we have been seeing
in this great recession
is that employment
growth by small business
relative to employment growth
by large business is way down.
And the cyclic behavior of the
two generally is different.
And what we're seeing
now is an unusual amount,
which I think is connected
to exactly what Bob
was talking about, the financial
stretch-out of households
and of banks.
I think that affects the
financing not of big business,
but of small business
and in terms of hiring.
That's an important
part of the story.
ACEMOGLU: Since we
are running late
and we don't want to eat too
much more into the lunch time,
I think we're going to have
only time for one more question.
Sorry for the remaining people
who wanted to ask questions.
AUDIENCE: Hopefully this
is worth your while, then.
I'm Doug Carr, a Sloan grad.
Obviously the issue of
the size of government
is a huge controversy today.
There are studies
and economics--
Barrow, I believe, has found
that larger size of government
relative to the economy has
associated with it a lower
rate of long-term growth.
And I think there may be other
studies that refute his study.
Within the field
of growth theory,
is there a framework for
analyzing this issue?
SOLOW: Certainly a
framework for analyzing it.
The difficulty in dealing
with associations like that
is to translate it into a causal
mechanism one way or another.
It is of course
perfectly possible
that large government budgets
waste resources and affect
the level of output that way.
It's also possible that
slow-growing economies
tend to depend more on
governmental intervention
than fast-growing ones.
My own feeling
about this is that
what's more important
to begin with is
to talk less about growth
and more about levels.
One could easily make
a sensible argument
one way or another about
the size of government
relative to the economy and
the efficiency of the economy.
But that's a matter of a
level change, not a change
in something that's potentially
part of a steady-state rate
of growth.
So I tend to be suspicious of
all simple generalizations that
go from some current
fraction to an implication
about steady-state or
near-steady-state rates
of growth.
DIAMOND: Bob has--
if I can characterize
that-- says he's
skeptical about an answer
to that question,
Barrow's or the opposite.
I'm skeptical about the
value of the question.
And this also relates with
what Esther was saying.
Esther was saying, more
aid, less aid, wrong debate.
What we want is good aid.
More government, less
government, wrong debate.
There's good things
the government spends
on that helps, if you'll
excuse the expression,
economic growth, or
efficiency in the economy.
And you do more of it,
then the level goes up,
and that's growth.
Regulation-- is it more
regulation or less regulation?
Now, Bob was saying it's the
quality of the regulation.
I was a little
surprised that dropping
the regulation on leverage,
which you referred to
as a policy lapse, isn't in the
category of a bad deregulation.
Not that the whole
system was deregulated,
if that's what the term
means, but I think,
on regulations, there were
good and bad ones, on aid,
there's good and bad,
on government spending,
there's good and bad.
And the idea that
you look at the whole
and then move from
that, somehow,
into policy and politics
seems, to me, misguided.
SOLOW: Let me add
one more thing.
This is what they call a
teachable moment, I think.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Teaching me?
SOLOW: No, no, no.
No, no, no.
No, teaching the world.
[LAUGHTER]
A government that
spends money, which
would appear as a larger
government, supporting higher
education, supporting
technological innovation,
supporting R&D generally,
certainly has a prayer--
more than a prayer--
a likelihood
of affecting the steady
state rate of growth.
A government that botches food
and drug regulation or that
spends more or less will
affect the current efficiency
of the economy, but won't affect
the rate-- to that extent,
I think that's
what Peter had mind
by saying he disagreed
with the question.
ACEMOGLU: Bob Hall.
HALL: Okay, great question.
All right, so as
it happens, I've
done research on this question,
published a paper on it,
which agrees extremely strongly
with both Bob and Peter.
In the first place, it
was in a levels framework,
which I strongly agree with.
What matters is the level.
Growth is just a way
you get to the level.
Second, it examines
this question
of how government relates
to economic success.
And the answer is, very
clearly, size is not important.
And you can see
that in Scandinavia.
Scandinavia has governments
that historically
have been very involved
in the economy,
but has achieved
excellent results.
And then you see
some economies that
have very small governments
that have terrible results.
What shows through
unambiguously is competence.
What we want is a
government that knows
what it's doing, everywhere.
Now, luckily, that's
pretty much what we have.
The US does have-- it stands at
the very top in terms of output
per worker, and generally,
with a government that
does a good job of providing
an environment in which
private activity can flourish
with the government being
assigned the right things to do.
There's a few exceptions,
like the post office.
But generally, this
country gets things right.
And if you go to another
country and see governments
floundering, then you
can appreciate that.
ACEMOGLU: Okay I think I
would like to thank the four
panelists again for--
[APPLAUSE]